uh so welcome to this lecture this is uh
the first lecture on physics informed
noral networks so I'm going to be
introducing physics inform form noral
networks in this
lecture
um before I get started on physics
informal networks I just want to recap
what Sid talked to you about uh last
week and he talked about the importance
of partial differential equations and
PDS really are the fundamental
building blocks that we used to describe
and understand you know many different
scientific
phenomena uh from you know this very
smallest of scales using for example the
Shing equation to model the Dynamics of
atoms so the very largest scales and
using for example Einstein's equations
to model black
holes um pdes are also really important
to understand phen phenomena that happen
here on Earth so for example
The navor Stokes equations are really
essential for understanding how the
climate evolves in the flu dynamics of
the
climate and then what's amazing is that
some biological systems can also be
described by pdes so for example the
reaction diffusion equation can be used
to model how the patterns on animal skin
evolve over time as they as they
grow so this is why we place a lot of
emphasis on pdes in this course um and
physics form networks are a way to solve
differential equations or a way to solve
problems related to differential
equations and I'm going to show you
exactly how pins physics informal
networks uh can do
this so yeah this is the first of of
quite a few lectures on physics and
formal networks we're now really into
the main body of the course where we're
getting into these kind of new
scientific machine learning techniques
that we've been talking about so far
so yeah how does this lecture look so
first of all I'm going to give you a
very high level description of what
physics and form nor networks are a
really simple
description then hopefully if it works
I'm going to try and do some live coding
to show you just how easy it is to train
a physics inform noral Network in
pytorch just in a few lines of
code and then I'm going to really
justify why we use pins and all the
different applications that you can use
them for so it turns out you can use
them not only just to solve differential
equations so carrying out forward
simulation tasks but you can also use
them to carry out inverse problems uh
this is you know discovering underlying
parameters of a system given some
observations of that system and you can
even use pins to start discovering the
PD itself so the terms of the the PD so
so pins are really flexible framework
and really interesting uh field of
research to study
so by the end of the lecture you should
be able to explain precisely what
physics inform new network is and how to
train one um and all the different kind
of applications that we use pins for and
all the different tasks that you can use
a pin
for okay so what is a physics inform
neural
network so before I describe exactly
what a pin is um I want you to have a
thing about how you might use a newal
network to solve a differential equation
so Sid last lecture talked about all
these traditional numerical methods we
have so things like finite difference
methods finite element methods and he
talked about the pros and cons of those
methods but pins are fundamentally
different they useing the network to
solve the differential
equation so I just want you to start off
the morning just talk with your partner
about um ways that you could use a nor
Network to either solve a differential
equation or help you solve the
differential
equation um so I'll give you a couple of
minutes and then and then I'll I'll see
what you've come up with just have a
quick
discussion it's a very broad
question okay so it's just a very quick
discussion so can anyone give me a hand
uh of a way that you thought of using a
nor Network to to solve a differential
equation to carry out simulation
yeah yeah
and
is
yeah yeah s so to repeat so you would
have a newal network that would take in
the input of the network would be these
initial conditions
so by the way this is the an example of
solving the wave equation with you know
the acoustic wave equation here and some
initial conditions and this output here
is the is the output of a finite
difference
solver so you might have a NE Network
that takes the's inputs and then tries
to produce the simulation as output and
you train it maybe based on lots of
examples from finite difference modeling
for example yeah in in a supervised
manner yeah yep definitely any any other
ideas
[Music]
yeah yeah
yeah yeah this is a really good idea and
so this is this is very similar to what
pins do so the idea is to instead of
generating lots of data to train the
network which is very expensive in
general if you have to remember I was
saying in the in the introduction to
deep learning we need thousands millions
of examples to train deep neural
networks and that could take hours or
days to compute on a on a traditional
simulation so we could use a wave
equation directly to train the network
and minimize the it's or penalize the
difference uh using the wave equation
that would be better yet so that's a
great start to thinking about physics
informed neural networks so so let let's
now start to think what a pin is
so I'm going to I'm going to take an
even easier differential equation this
is an ordinary differential equation um
and it's the it's the equation for a
damped harmonic oscillator so this is a
canonical problem in physics and it just
models you know a mass on the spring
what what is the displacement of this
mass as a function of
time and we know that the displacement U
here is a function of time just obeys
this this differential equation where M
here is the mass of the
oscillator um mu is the coefficient of
friction so it's some dampening term and
then K is the spring spring
constant and so we get this um depending
on the kind of regime of the oscillator
you can have over damped and underdamped
and critically damped regimes this is
the this is the um underdamped regime
where the where the oscillator slowly
decays over time so we have this sign
sign of sodial function with with an
exponential
decay and so we we know you know in
general to be able to solve a
differential equation we have to give it
a unique set of initial conditions and
boundary conditions to give us a
particular solution so the appropriate
ones here are to say uh the mass is
going to start with a displacement of
one and a velocity of zero that allows
us to uniquely and in this case
analytically solve solve the
OD okay so how are we going to try and
solve this uh this equation using AAL
Network and what I mean by solving is we
want to be able to uh compute this
function let's just assume that we don't
know what it is analytically because for
the vast majority of PDs we don't know
what the analytical solution
is so pins are very very simple the the
underlying idea of a pin is very simply
to approximate the solution directly
with the neural
network so we say my solution UF UFT is
is approximated by this function
remember neural networks are just
functions that fit to data
so it's a neural network function that
takes in the coordinate t or the time
value T and and has some free parameters
Theta um so just to be very explicit we
typically for Pins we start with an MLP
this is usually the model that we start
with and so the MLP has a single in this
case a single scalar input it's the time
value and then it gives you a single
scalar output and that's the that's the
uh prediction of the of the
displacement so one question already is
how is this solution that we get from
this technique different to the solution
from for example finite difference
modeling can anyone tell
me just just by the way that we're
framing the framing the problem
here okay so I I I'll tell you um what
we're doing here that's fundamentally
different to finite difference modeling
is is we're making a functional
approximation to solution so this this
the output of our of the pin is a is a
function that we can query at any point
in time and it will give us its
approximation in the solution that's not
the case when we run finite difference
modeling what we get from finite
difference modeling is a discretized
version of the solution we get the
solution on the value of the solution
where on the measure points that we
use so one key property of pins is is
this idea of them being mesh free
they're a mesh free approach they don't
we don't need a mesh compute the
solution
okay so then the question is what loss
function that we use to train the pin
and this is where we put in this
information of the differential equation
as you were suggesting um into the loss
function so we have two two loss
functions uh one is called or two
components to the loss function one is
called the boundary loss and one is
called the physics loss sometimes it's
called the PD residual I'm just going to
refer to it as the physics loss going
forwards um and it's very simple what
we're saying is with the boundary loss
that the neural network should match
whatever our initial conditions are so
let's take the first this this boundary
loss has two terms let's take the first
term it says that the the output of the
neural network at T equals Zer should
just equal one and so that's exactly
saying you know this initial condition
displacement starts starts at
one the second term in the boundary loss
is to say that the derivative of the
network with respect to T should equal
zero and again that's just saying that
the velocity should equal zero that's
our initial
condition then the final one which is
the most important is this uh physics
loss and what this does is it computes
the residual of the of the underlying
differential
equation so we take our Neal Network and
we just evaluate all the gradients
required so you know the derivatives
with respect to time that required to to
compute this left hand side of the of
the differential
equation and and if this solution
exactly matches you know is a true
solution of the differential equation
what is the value that we expect this to
be if Neal network is a true
solution yes zero yeah um you know
that's that's what the differential
equation says so we try and make sure
that this residual is as close to zero
as possible and if it is then the Neal
network is giving us a true a true
solution um now we have to evaluate this
residual at many different points in the
domain so we sample over many different
time values to make sure that across the
entire solution domain this this
residual of the differential equation is
is
obeyed so uh you can think of the
boundary loss as you know as a asserting
the boundary conditions and making sure
that the solution is unique and then the
physics loss is making sure that the
underlying equation is is a at all
points in the in the
domain and here's what happens if I
train a fully connected neural network
um using exactly this this loss function
here um and what you're seeing is the
gray curve is the exact solution and the
and the blue curve is the neural network
F uh or or the neex prediction of the
displacement as a function of the
training
step now I'm also plotting a couple of
points here so what I'm plotting the the
boundary point so this is just t equal Z
here this is uh this is the boundary
point that we're matching to in the loss
function we just have one point in this
case for this single 1D
equation and then the green points here
are these what we call physics lost
training locations or we also call them
the collocation points
so these are these are the time points
here that we sample the physics loss
over to make sure that the differential
equation is is obeyed at all points in
the
domain so this is a Super Key slide to
really understand every element in the
slide everything that um we're going to
talk about in the in the remaining
lectures on pins is is going to come
back to these core ideas of how we train
pins and how they're defined so has
anyone got any questions before we move
on yeah we' got so the train of
comp
yes absolutely yep so really good
observation if if I take this train nor
Network that I've trained here and I
give it a Time coordinate that's outside
of the domain it's very likely that
that's not going to obey the underlying
solution because it's outside of the
training distribution of the network so
the generalization of no networks is
still still an issue here y so we're
going to talk about that in in the next
lecture as well
yep right so um we're training this
network just how we train a normal noral
network with gradient
descent so we take you know we take the
gradient of the loss function with
respect to the weights so we take a step
so what what I'm showing here is the
prediction of the network as a function
of training step in every step we could
use all the all the training locations
like all the ti yes yeah so
we yeah yeah
so unlike what we normally do with nor
networks where we use mini batches and
we we do like small batches of of
training points what is more often the
case in pins is just to use full full
batch training so you give it all the
points at every training step so all of
these green points and all the orange
points in this training example are
being used every step
yep any other
questions yeah
yeah yeah so so you don't have to so
other and it's good to compare when
you're training pins um and it often
depends on the type of problem that
you're solving as well um to me it makes
more sense because it makes the problem
more well
posed in that you've uh you're making
sure that the PD loss is consistent
everywhere and there needs to be
Comm like a deeper level there needs to
be communication like we need to be able
to without this boundary Point here we
could learn any solution to the to this
differential equation and it could start
anywhere in for example so somehow we
need to communicate this banding point
across the across the en time and
forwards and solve it causely so having
all these points can can help do that
rather than just randomly
sampling yeah we'll talk about that more
as well
yeah way
Lear yes
yeah I think it comes from uh what I'm
talking about when we when we need to
communicate or propagate the boundary
conditions forward in time we don't know
we don't know what the solution is here
until we've learned what the solution is
before it to constrain the value like to
solve the the the the equation forwards
in
time so so and but I mean in general
it's very difficult to understand the
training dynamics of physics inform
networks this is actually quite
difficult so this is my kind of my
empirical observations but to analyze it
mathematically is a really interesting
topic as well to to think about the
training Dynamics so yeah we'll talk
about that as well coming up so yeah
okay
y
yeah yeah so we're going to talk um uh
next about extensions of pins and so
physics and forur networks is an entire
research buiild and there's a lot of
clever ways to make them generalize
better to speed them up to improve their
limitations so I I'll talk about
this
okay uh I'm just going to check the chat
as well because it looks like we have a
question
um oh no it's just a suggestion okay
um okay
so as I mentioned uh these TI these
green points in the domain are known as
collocation points and we sample them
through the
domain um and one other thing I haven't
talked about so far is these Lambda
values and you can see that they uh are
just weights that we apply to each term
in the loss function and what we do is
that we just consider them as hyper
parameters that allow us to um scale or
balance the contribution of each of the
terms in the loss function
and so in practice this is really
important to make sure that the pin
converges
quickly if you set for example the
boundary weights to be very very low
then you might just learn a different
Solution that's not the true the true
particular solution of the of the
differential
equation um
okay so I showed you a pin for the dmic
oscillator what's what makes pins so
powerful and why they're so such a
popular or heavily research field today
is that this is they are actually a
general framework for solving partial
differential equations so I can take
this idea of just using a noral network
to to represent the solution of a
differential equation and train train it
on any differential equation I
like so we can set up pins in a more
abstract way and and say uh given some
PD and I'm not being specific about what
PDA is and some boundary initial
conditions um so we can just say that
the PD in general is just some
differentiable operator differential
operator that's applied to the solution
that gives us maybe some function as
function as
output where we have some domain in some
D dimensional
space so for example a 3D problem with X
Y and T for
example and we have some boundary
operators we might have K of them for
example we might have a a bound initial
condition on the velocity and the and on
the value of the solution
itself uh equals again some boundary
function here evaluated on the
boundaries of the
domain this can Define precisely our our
our uh PD or boundary value problem that
we want to
solve
um I'm also you can also incorporate
time here into X so I haven't explicitly
said the time is here but it could be
incorporated into this
Vector um so pins train an oral Network
to approximate the solution to the PD uh
by directly approximating the solution
so this is a functional approximation of
the solution and we use these two uh
loss terms that I just described so we
have the boundary loss where you know we
have a separate loss term for each
boundary condition each K boundary
condition and we have a physics loss
that minimizes the residual of that
underlying differential
equation okay so to make it more
concrete for you and to show you an
application of a PIN to a different uh
partial differential
equation I'm just going to consider the
burgers equation so this model's fluid
flow uh and this is the viscous Burg equ
Burgers equation so we have some
viscosity parameter new
here and U here now represents the the
speed of the
flow um and we're thinking about the
flow just through a on dsection as a
function of time so the the solution
here is the flow wherever you are on
that section and then a function of
time so we set up these initial
conditions we just say that the starting
starting flow is some um s
function in X and then we have some
bound condition saying at the edges of
the domain the flow should be zero so
what we're actually modeling here is the
fluid flow through a through a pipe for
example where the fluid starts with a
sign of AAL distribution of its
velocity okay okay so then we say yeah
the solution is approximated by
an and then we do exactly as we did
before we have we have our boundary
boundary loss here where we have now
three terms in our boundary loss which
are asserting each of these uh these
three boundary
conditions so you know normal Network
across all points in X but at time
equals zero we want to match to the
negative sign function so we need to
sample all the like sample many possible
values of X when we're evaluating this
term then this term says xsus one but
for all values of T we should make sure
that it's zero and for xals plus one the
same
thing and then the physics loss we're
just evaluating um this the residual of
the of the full differential equation
sampling over all Poss all possible
values of x and t in our
domain
okay so that's let me show you a picture
of what that looks like um this is the
same loss function again but what I'm
plotting um here is the black points and
the green points the black points
represent where we sampled the the
boundary loss
from so when we did the 1D harmonic
oscillator we only needed one boundary
point because it was 1D but in higher
Dimensions you need to sample you know
the sub the Subspace of the
domain so um we're sampling across the
the edges of the domain here for these
boundary boundary losss here
and then the green points here are where
we're sampling the the physics
loss you can also see that we're not
doing a r a uniform sampling anymore we
can also do a random sampling in the
domain and actually um random or quasi
random sampling can actually improve or
help the convergence of pins and we'll
talk about that coming
up and uh yeah this is actually plotted
here is the solution of the pin and and
so what you can see is uh again this is
the fluid flow through a pipe and we
started with a sinal sodial fluid flow
and what's interesting about the burgers
equation and what makes it nice to study
is that uh as time of as time goes
forwards this the fluid starts to form a
shock and you start getting flow that
goes one way and and the other way and
you get a shock in the
middle and so this is quite an
interesting problem to study especially
when we're using numerical methods
because we can start to get really big
discretization eras where we have these
dis discontinuities in the solution
and what's nice to see is if you plot
the kind of exact solution um against
what the normal Network predicts after
it's been trained it does somehow model
this shock fairly well um in in its
solution and gets quite a good match to
to the true
solution so this is a plot that was
taken directly from uh Rice's physics
informed networks paper which is kind of
the seminal paper on physics informed
networks
uh so um to be more specific about kind
of the setup that they used and it's
important to understand kind of these
these fine details uh they used 10,000
uh prolation points in the physics loss
here um and they used not uniform
sampling but this thing called Latin
hyic Cube sampling which is pseudo
pseudo random
sampling um and then they had 100 100
100 boundary points sampled yeah along
the boundary here the network they used
was fully connected Network nine nine
layers 20 hidden units so that turns out
to be 3,000 free parameters that we need
to fit this flexible flexible function
to the
solution um and then we use a tan
activation function and a a second order
Optimizer so not not just uh gradient
descent but but uh yeah Quai quazi
Newton uh
Optimizer so
um one interesting thing is the
activation function so can anyone tell
me why why they chose to use a t
activation function here instead of say
for example a relo
activation
yeah uh
yes yeah yeah exactly so the answer was
that reu can give always gives positive
outputs that's true what we typically do
um when we do newal Networks regression
is we don't use an activation for the
final layer which gives us the
opportunity to have negative
values uh but the real reason why we
would use a t h is that it's a
continuously differentiable and smooth
function so why is that important why do
we need a continuously differentiable
function or activation
function
yes yeah exactly we need to be able to
evaluate the second order derivative
here of the newal network with respect
to its inputs so if I used a relo
activation what would that value
be remember relo activation is a
piecewise linear
function yeah yeah so the the gradients
of the piecewise linear function the
second of derivative is zero of a of a
noral network that uses a Reload
activation
function uh so that's really important
thing to understand uh it's often
overlooked when we train your NS they're
actually making piecewise linear
approximations if we use read so that
but if we use a t activation then we
have a in general a continuously
differentiable function that we can
fit so you don't have to just use P you
can use other kind of smooth
approximations of the reload functions
uh there are these swish functions for
example or or others that you can use
so I've been hinting that pins uh uh is
in an entire research field by this by
this point um
um and if you look at the number of
Publications that uh have the keyword
physics and formal nwks in them you can
just see that the amount of papers
published on pins each year has just
been growing very very quickly and
um there's it's a whole research field
there are so many extensions of pins and
we'll cover some some of them in the in
the lectures coming up but if you really
want to get into physics and formula in
more detail you can have a look at this
review paper which is a fairly good
comprehensive review of of all the
research landscape on pins to
date it's actually quite interesting to
note that the kind of basic concepts
behind pins so this idea of using an or
network to approximate the solution and
then train it using this residual of
your differential equation these basic
ideas can be found in papers going back
all the way to the 1990s for example
larus and and others
uh but but the paper that uh is most
well known for Pins is is Rice's paper
and this is the kind of seminal paper
which reimplemented and and extended
pins using modern deep learning
Frameworks and showing that we can we
can train you know deep fully connected
networks uh and other networks to to to
solve these differential
equations
okay so hopefully I've described to you
a high level what a pin is um so now I'm
going to talk in much more detail about
the training uh process of training the
pins there's quite a lot of factors that
I haven't talked about or I've left out
so
far and I'm gonna hopefully at this SE
in this section talk to you about or or
do a live coding of a pin and py talks
to show you how easy it is to train in
pych so let's think about the the
training Loop of a physics and formal
Network in more detail so let's go back
to this harmonic oscillator example
which is
um you know a simple example to think
about again we have our boundary loss
and we have our physics
loss and so this is how the training
Loop would look if I just write it down
as a as a as a a list so we would first
start by just sampling our boundary
points and our physics training points
or our cocation points so not the orange
point and the Green Point
here then we would compute our gr our
Network
output and then the important thing is
we need to evaluate the derivative of
the network with respect to its in so
these DN by DT and DN by DT squares to
be able to compute this this physics
loss and also the boundary loss
here then that allows us to actually
compute the value of the loss function
but then we need to do another step
where we need to take the gradient of
the loss function with respect to the
normal Network parameters in order to
update the parameters to learn the
solution so the key question here is how
do we compute the gradients that we
require so you know DN by DT and DL by D
Theta so can anyone tell me how we how
we would compute
those or even if they're available y
y yeah yeah so in
general the neural network here is just
the mathematical function remember it's
just a bunch of linear operations plus
some activation functions so we can
write down analytically the derivative
of the network with respect to its input
that something we can actually
analytically derive if if you had a pen
and paper you could do
it um and as I described in the
introduction to deep learning lectures
we don't actually do that in practice we
can just use the autod differentiation
and back propagation as an efficient way
to compute those
gradients
so the important thing is we can use
autoi not just to get the gradients of
the loss function with effect to the
weights but also we can use autoi to get
the gradients of the network um uh of
the network outputs with respect to its
inputs same algorithm same Auto
different can be
used so let me just show you how we
would use aut diff to get both of those
gradients and let's just think let's
just make assume that the network is a
MLP so a fully connected Network that
has this this
form and
um we used the chain rule when we were
differentiating the loss function with
respect to the weights to get to to be
able to evaluate that that gradient so
we can use very analogously the chain
will to now compute the gradients of the
network with respect to its input so a
different gradient but very
similar so we just note that the no
network function is just composed of
these uh ve these Vector
functions and we just use the chain Ru
to find out what the derivative of the
network with respector his inputs are
and you can uh derve this analytically
like I said I don't have the time to do
it today but this is an exercise that
you can go away and do and so we can
just show that the derivative of the
network with respect time is just is
this expression
here
okay so then how do we get once we've
got this once we've evaluated this
derivative how do we get now the
derivative of the loss function with
respect to the weights that's that's the
the next derivative that we
need so we can just to do this we can
use a to diff and we can simply just
think of computing these uh derivatives
of the network with respect to its
inputs as extending our comp compal
graph when we're using Auto
differentiation so Auto diff works by
you know creating a a graph of all your
operations and tracking that graph and
then back propagating through that graph
to to give you your to give you your
gradients so this gradient here the Der
of the network with respect to time is
just some extra computation you can just
think of it as an extra computation
which just extends this forward path
this forward graph of the network so you
know this this derivative just depends
on the activations G and H and it passes
them through some functions which are
derivatives of the activation functions
and times it by weights so we can just
we can just plot that as an an extra
part of our computational graph which
then allows us to compute the final
output of the graph which is the is the
Lost
function so once we've extended our
computational graph then we can just
call autoi on the entire graph this all
combined graph to back propagate through
from the loss function to back propagate
through it to get the the gradients of
the the
weights so this is the kind of key key
realization is that we can recursively
apply UT to first get our gradients to
the network with respect to its inputs
create a new graph and then get the
gradients of that graph with respect to
the networks parameters uh to update the
parameters
themselves so this is how it would look
uh in some pseudo code of of of iny
torch and so
uh like I said you can just get you can
in practice just use autograd to get
these
gradients and so you would have uh T
here is our is our time coordinate Theta
is our parameters of our
Network we get the prediction of the
network given the value of T and then we
compute our first gradient which is our
derivative of the output the network
with respect to time and we can just use
autograd to to get this we also need the
second order derivative with respect to
time to evaluate the the physics loss
and the key thing we do in pytorch is we
do this thing called create graph equals
true and that extends the computational
grph so that we can then differentiate
through it again when we call autograd
the final time to get the gradient at
the loss function with respect to the
weights hopefully this makes sense does
anyone have any questions on on on how
we get these two
gradients okay
so now we have everything we need to
actually train a pin uh in pyto auction
to actually code up a pin and so I'm
gonna attempt to to do some live coding
for
you um so for the people in Zoom I'm
just GNA stop sharing and try and share
my
screen my Chrome
screen okay so hopefully you can see
that
okay
um so what I have here is a is a Jupiter
notebook um and I've got a lot of the
code here is already filled in I'm just
going to be adding a couple of lines the
key lines for training the the physics
and form
Network so we're going to be using
pytorch so I'm just everyone can see
this second yeah and we're going to be
using pytor so I'm just going to import
the relevant
libraries okay so again we're going to
be training a PIN to solve this stamp
harmonic oscillator um I've already told
you about the differential equation uh
there are different regimes we're going
to be focusing on the underap state here
where we have this kind of decay of the
of the
solution analytically we can you can
actually show that the solution has this
form so it's a you know a cosine
function as a function of time D damped
by this exponential factor and it's if
you're interested in kind of deriving
this I would have a check out of this
blog post it's very very useful for
understanding okay so the first thing
we're going to do is just simulate the
system using the pin so we're going to
try and solve this this differential
equation so I've got a couple of kind of
pre-computed or predefined functions
here this this is just a function that
computes the exact solution given some
parameters so so here omega0 is the is
the uh is the base frequency of the
solution which just depends on a the
spring constant and the mass and again
um Delta here is determines how much
dampening we have and it depends again
on the on the coefficient of fiction and
the mass
so given given these two values we can
figure out what the exact solution is
and then this is just a class in in
pytorch which just defines standard
fully connected Network and I'm not
going to describe this I think we
already C covered this in the tutorials
with you so hopefully this is familiar
to
you okay so we're going to train uh the
PIN to with exactly the Lost function
I've been describing in the lectures
here and we're going to be using torch
autograd to get these
gradients um
and so this is the this block here is
the main block that we're going to be
using to train train the network and you
can see already that it's not many lines
of code like in pych we can do this with
10 10 lines of code or
so and it should be very similar to uh
uh or it should be very it should look
very similar to you when you've been
training normal nor networks and so we
start by just creating a nor Network um
a fully connected Network which here
just has 32 hidden units and three three
layers then we set up our Optimizer um
and then we have a standard training
Loop here where we're we're taking we're
getting a loss function and we're back
propagate back propagating through the
loss function so this is standard P
torch
code so what I'm going to do is um what
what I need to do is Define the boundary
loss and the physics loss in this code
and so first thing to do is to Define
this is this boundary loss and so the
first thing we need is to define the
point that we're evaluating the boundary
and so this for this problem is just a
single point so we're going to see say
that t t at the
boundary um there's a torch Po tenser
and it's the value zero so we're going
to be passing t equal Z into the
network so the other thing we need to do
um is that because we need gradients of
the Network's output with respect to uh
this input coordinate we need to tell py
to start tracking the computational
graph that that uh that is created when
we use this uh when we use this
tensor so this this just says track
track graph so that we can later get
gradients with respect to this
tensor so we do this requires grad uh
here mostly just going to change the
shape of the tensor so that it's it's
just appropriate for feeding it into the
network we also have to Define our
physics uh training points so these are
the collocation points that we use to
evaluate the the physics loss so it's
going to look very similar but now we
need uh we need more than one point we
need to sample the points across the
domain so I'm just going to do a simple
uniform sampling of the points from Z to
one which is our domain that we're going
to be solving the
um uh this the domain that we're going
to be solving the the differential
equation
over uh so where are we yeah and we'll
we'll take 30 30 points and again we're
going to need to requireed
gradient and we're going to make a nice
view of the with the
data okay so so now we've got our points
that we're going to feed into the
network now we need to compute these
loss values in our training
Loop so the first thing we need to do is
the boundary loss and the first boundary
condition that we want is that the
solution should be one at T equals z
and so we're going to say first we need
to compute the solution using the pin so
we say we just call the pin with our
with our boundary
point and then we want the loss the
first loss to be the difference between
the networks prediction and
one and we're going to square
this a very simple uh first loss
function the only other thing I'm going
to do is squeeze it which just turns it
into a Scala value which is appropriate
for for p
torch okay so then the next term we now
need to bring in autograd to get the
derivative of network with respect spe
input to get the to make sure that the
velocity of the oscillator is is zero at
the
start so how do we do this so we say we
use autograd so we say du by
DT um equals torch
autograd grad this is our core kind of
gradient computation using
autograd um and we want uh the
derivative of the output with respect to
the andry point so p. autograph
autograph makes it very easy to get
these gradients and this is just how we
how we Define it in py
torch so um um an important thing to
note so this is the documentation for a.
autograd dogr and what it actually does
behind the scenes is um compute the
vector Jacobian products so in general U
here is a is a vector function of of T
and what this this uh autograph all does
is actually give you Vector Times by The
Jacobian of that Vector function now if
that's confusing to you don't worry I'm
going to be explaining what autograd is
in much more detail in the second half
of the course uh when we talk about
differentiable physics um but for now
all I need to do is just specify what
that Vector is that I'm Computing the
vectors of probium product with and that
can just be a a vector of ones for now
so so we'll just do torch uh do On's
like uh the
solution the final thing we need to do
is this crate graph flag which I
explained before makes us build the
computation graph so that we can then
differentiate through it again when we
evaluate the gradient of the L
function um and I know that this returns
a two and we need the first element of
of the two
so uh so so this should just be a vector
the same shape as U that just has the
gradient of U with respect to
C um and then we can just go ahead and
compute our second determine the
boundary loss which is just uh you know
the difference between du by DT and zero
so we're saying the velocity is going to
be zero at time equals zero going to
square it and we're also going to do the
squeezing as well or.
squeeze
okay so we're nearly there now now what
we have to do is is compute the physics
loss and we're going to use exactly the
same autog pools to get these uh the the
extra gradients that we
need so the first thing to do is now to
compute the pin not at the boundary
points but now at the physics points so
across the domain so T
physics and then I'm going to copy I'm
going to copy this
line um and paste it twice and uh I'm
going to pass the physics points instead
of the bandage
points like
this and what's neat about autoi is that
we can again recursively apply Auto
recursively apply Auto diff to our
competition graph so for getting the
second order derivative with Vector time
we can just pass in uh you know this
object here which is tracked by the
computational graph so you know our
velocity
Vector so now we've got all the
derivatives that we need uh to compete
the physics the physics loss and so we
can just do that by uh doing loss three
is the mean across all the C location
points of uh and now we just type in the
underlying PD residual so this is
let's just go back to what it looks like
it's uh the mass which we're just
assuming in this case is one to make it
simple uh Times by the second derivative
plus plus the coefficient of friction
Times by the first derivative plus K
evaluated on the
network so we can just do
this D by DT plus mu Times
by U by DT 2 plus mu * d by DT + K by U
and then we want we want to square this
to make sure that we're doing the the
squared
error so I'm just going to double check
this to make sure that I've not made any
mistakes um so I think this should be
fine this should be
fine that looks
fine okay so I think it's okay so let's
give it a run and if it's not I'll I'll
try and deug
it so the rest of the code here is just
plotting uh as training progresses it's
just plotting the pin solution so we're
querying the pin a set of test test
locations a much finer sampling density
than the physics loss yeah and it looks
like it's working and so uh yeah this is
the animation I show you in the lecture
so as as the pin converges we we start
to converge on the
solution and these green points here are
those physics points that I Ed to train
and the red point is that boundy point
so anyone have any questions on the on
the code before I go back to the the
lecture
yeah exactly
yeah yeah yeah
so yeah so so you can choose the
important thing is you just have a
relative balance between the terms it
doesn't matter what the magnitude of the
terms are or it does uh but when we use
Adam it does this automatic scaling so
we don't have to worry about the
absolute magnitude but it's it's an
important question to think
about I chose these by the way by just
uh by just doing the experiments myself
and and changing these values by hand
but there are better ways to do this and
and I'll talk about that next lecture y
y backwards uh yeah you could um this is
just a pip thing that if I use when I
call torch L backwards it doesn't give
me a vector of the gradient it what it
does is it uh does the backrop through
the computational graph and accumulates
that gradient inside of the leaves of
the tree this is just the way that py
torch is framed uh
yeah yeah so we do need to do create
graph equal TR for here because we we
need to differentiate through this this
uh this derivative when we're getting
the gradient the loss function with
respect to the weights so we the final
sc. grad call is this loss.
backwards so we we need to build that
graph to be able to differentiate
through it when we update the
weights does that make sense
okay yeah anyone
else
okay so now I'm G to try and switch my
screen
again stop
share okay
right so
um what's important is to think about
the computational cost of evaluating
these derivatives like I've said that
they're available and we can compute
them analytically or you know
equivalently using Auto differentiation
but the cost of getting these
derivatives is can be quite
high so if you just think about the
computational graph uh that we build
when we add these extra computations to
compute these gradients with respect to
the inputs
you can see that these computations
roughly double the size of the
computational graph um if I go back to
this expression
here you know this this expression here
is has roughly without going into it in
detail you can see it has roughly the
same computational cost as the forward
pass of the network just to evaluate
this function
here um it's doing similar things right
it's timesing vectors by weight matrices
and passing them through derivatives of
activation functions kind of the same
computation
complexity so we can actually more
precisely uh you can derive that the
time that it takes to given some Vector
function here the time it takes to
compute the vect the Jacobian Vector
product uh is is approximately uh this
Omega so a constant value Times by the
time it takes to compute the forward
path of the network
only where Omega is some value between
two two and 2.5 and to really understand
that derivation you can you can have a
look at this this uh reference
here so it sounds good like we can
compute it in roughly the same amount of
time as the forward paths but uh we want
higher order derivatives when we're
training uh pins normally we want second
or derivatives or even high order
derivatives when we're evaluating this
physics loss and so this this grows cost
of evaluating this higher order
derivative grows exponentially with a
value of n so it we get this Omega to
the power of n kind of computational
scaling
so when you're training pins what you'll
normally find is most of the time spent
training it is not in the forward Paths
of the network but actually when we're
Computing the gradients and this is kind
of this is kind of a key kind of limit
or kind of limitation of the
computational cost of
pins there's a couple of other important
considerations which I think we've
pretty much talked talked about already
now and yeah the Lambda values really
significantly affect convergence and
often they're a key choice to Define
them
properly we also have to make sure that
we have enough collocation points in the
domain uh to make sure that we constrain
the PD residual precisely across the
whole whole
domain and enough is quite hard to
Define uh precisely um you know when we
when we when we do finite difference
methods finite element methods we have
very clear convergence criteria on on
what the sample sample spacing should be
for example um you might think for
example here we have a basically a sine
wave and so we'd want to make sure um
that the sample points uh below the N
sampling rate that would be a kind of a
sensible start to make sure that this
converges um and simly we need enough
boundary points to make sure that the L
solution is unique um we can we can
sample these collocation points randomly
or or or uniformly if we if we like and
as someone pointed out at the very start
uh pins even though they have this kind
of clever physics loss inside of them
they're still a newal network at the end
of the day and they still suffer from
all of these error sources that I talked
about in the in the introduction to De
learning lecture so they still have
approximation error if this if this
noral network is not flexible or
expressive enough to represent this true
solution it's not going to converge to
that solution they have estimation error
if we don't choose enough collocation
points we'll we'll converge on a
solution that's not the minimiz is the
true expected
loss and optimization error like even
though we might have an or network that
can give us a
solution this might be a very
complicated objective function for the
optimizer and it still might not
converge so yeah next lecture we'll talk
about how we can get over some of these
limitations when we're training
pins and if you compare this to kind of
find that element find method method F
difference methods where we have like
analytical bounds on the convergence
this is a kind of very different setup
the final way to look at pins before I
talk about move on and talk about the
applications of where we use pins um is
to reframe pins from a machine learning
perspective and I think it's really
interesting you know given this course
is AI in science and engineering and the
Very intersection of of these two Fields
it can be very useful to look at these
techniques from a more a pure machine
learning
perspective and so from a mathematical
perspective you know we've set these
these nor networks up to solve partial
differential equations there are
functional approximations to the
solution um well what can we say about
pins from a machine learning perspective
if purely from the perspective of
training a normal Network what's
interesting about this this loss
function can anyone make some
observations about about the
loss I'll make it um a bit easier for
you
um imagine if we just interpret this
boundary loss as like a supervised loss
you know we have the neural network here
and we're matching it so some labeled
training data here like one and zero
were saying that it should equal these
values so what's different about the
physics
loss
yeah yeah it's more like a so you said
it's more like a regular regularization
ter
which is exactly right so so the physics
loss here it doesn't need any
labels you know if we're thinking about
this from a supervised learning versus
unsupervised learning uh
framework the boundary loss has these
labels what what we want the solution to
be the physics loss or we give it a
these P points these inputs to the
network and it evaluates this loss
function based on just those inputs of
the
network so from an ml perspective we can
think of the physics loss as an
unsupervised regularizer
which is asserting prior knowledge it's
giving us this induct uh kind of it's
not an inductive bias but like a a
regularization term that pushes the
types of solutions that the network
learns towards solutions that obey the
differential
equation so this is a really nice way to
think of it from a machine learning
perspective it's a regularization
term so let me just make that like super
clear this is a different this is a
different way that you can train pins
where instead of having this like
specific boundary loss you can just say
okay what if I have a bunch of Sol bunch
of observations of the solution uh you
know these orange points here then if I
just train like a standard nor network
with a supervised loss on those on those
observational points you can see that
the network you know fits the data very
well within its training uh training
range but as soon as I query the network
outside of that training data points uh
the solution just just flattens out and
it's really poor
approximation so now we think of the
physics loss is basically adding a
regularization and we extend the
cocation points further out outside of
the training points and we can start to
learn a more General General solution
with the caveat that if we test it with
a Time Point that's even further outside
of those cocation points it's not going
to perform very
well so hopefully that makes makes sense
from a machine learning
perspective and then if I step back to
an even higher level and we think about
these three board categories like talked
about in the first lecture of ways to
incorporate scientific principles into
into machine learning we're very much on
the left hand side here we're talking
about changing the loss function of the
N Network we're just using in a pin of
the standard n network architecture and
we're adding some scientific
understandings of the loss function to
to improve the performance of this of
this
network
okay so um we're going to take a break
and then I'm going to come back and talk
about the applications of of pins and
how we extend them to solve inverse and
equation Discovery problems so yeah let
take five
minutes I explained to you at the start
what a physics informal network is and I
showed you how to train it I did some
live coding um so now I'm going to talk
about the applications of pins so all
the different types of scientific tasks
that we can use physics and formal
networks to solve I've been focusing so
far um on simulation tasks solving the
differential equations but what I'm
going to try to show you is that we can
also use pins to solve inverse problems
and also equation Discovery
problems so let's just go back to uh the
kind of key scientific tasks that we
often want to solve and this is a slide
I showed in the in the course
introduction this is just an example
using the the wave equation so the
example of seismic simulation but you
can take any PD and and there would be
similar tasks associated with
it so forward simulation is a task of
you know given some input conditions to
the system so for example the a velocity
model of the Earth and the location of a
of an earthquake in that in the
earth can I predict the outputs of that
physical system so in this case what is
the amplitude of the seismic waves that
propagate through through that
media so we can say b b here the output
of the system uh just depends on some
some uh model of the system typically
this is a PD and and some inputs to the
system
a so an inverse problem is to to try and
do the reverse is to say given some
observations of of the outputs of the
system so in this case the wave field
the the seismic
amplitude can we invert for the
underlying structure of the Earth or or
where the location of the earthquake
is um then the final task is equation
Discovery this is the task of not not
only uh discovering input parameters but
actually understanding the underlying uh
differential equation or or model beh
behind all of this uh this
Dynamics so in this case maybe your
observational data would be the wave
field the The Source location and also
the Earth model itself and and given all
of that data and observations can we
invert for the underlying differential
equation which in this case is the the
acoustic wave
equation and and so what I'm going to
try and convince you in in the last part
of this lecture is is to say that pins
can solve all of these three categories
of of tasks and not just simulation
tasks
so I've got just one more example of of
pins uh doing simulation before I move
on to those other tasks so this is some
work that we did where we where we
solved the wave equation so that
equation that I just showed you um using
using
pins and so the task here is given a a
velocity model this is just describing
the velocity of the Earth and and in
this case I'm just assuming the Earth is
just a very simple horizontal layered
structure um and given a source location
in the middle of that can I predict how
the sismic waves propagate through
through that Earth model and so this is
actually what it looks like if I run a
ground trth simulation using finite
difference modeling and it's it's really
interesting to look at how these uh wave
Fields evolve over time we get a lot of
complicated physics that that happens so
we get a general kind of uh outwards uh
explosion of the source but then as we
hit these interfaces in the velocity
model we start to get these Reflections
at each
interface we also start to see
compression and expansion of the of the
wave wave field or the wavelet depending
on the velocity that it's going through
so it squashes up when the velocity is
slow um and we get we got lots of other
interesting effects as well um that can
occur in wave physics so in general this
is really interesting kind of problem to
model and to see if pins can model this
sort function and this function is much
more complicated than the kind of single
sinos AAL function that we were looking
at
before so how do we do this well the
setup is exactly the same as I've been
describing so here we have a fully
connected Neal Network which where the
output is just a scaler it's just the uh
essentially the pressure of the of the
seismic
wave which is what I'm showing in this
in this in this plot here and then the
input to the to the network we're going
to solve this in two in space and then
we have the time it's time bearing
problem so we have time as an extra
input to the
network now to make sure that the B the
network learns the boundary conditions
uh for this for this example what we did
is we just matched the network to a a
very small number of finite different
steps uh just for the very first 0.02
seconds of the simulation so basically
just this red box here we took as uh as
example supervised uh examples of the
solution to match the the network
to um and then we sampled the physics
loss using cocation points throughout
this
whole SpaceTime domain so all the way up
to time equals
0.2 um and uh so here's our results um
what I'm poting here is the PIN solution
here so so immediately you can see that
the physics and formal network is able
to model the solution which is really
interesting to see not only that um it
doesn't just get the the general
outwards Mo motion of the wave field it
also models these Reflections which is
you know it's just just learning to
model these Reflections based on
minimizing that PD
residual it hasn't seen these
Reflections in the training data in the
boundary condition conditions that it
was given so that's really cool to
see and then what I'm also plotting here
is um the output of a naive nor Network
so so is this network or how is this
naive Network trained so it's very
simply trained by only using the
boundary loss and not the physics loss
so we so This na Network just uses this
first term in the loss function here and
it's interesting to compare these two
solutions and so the naive Network
clearly models the boundary boundary
data very well where it has training
points where it doesn't have training
points it kind of captures the idea of
this Wayfield moving outwards but
doesn't understand about these
Reflections in the Wayfield so you can
really see see why the the physics and
form loss is essential for for getting
the correct Dynamics
here okay so so here are some of the
kind of more numerical details of this
of this network so um in this case
someone was asking about whether we use
full batch so in this case I used Mini
batch sampling so I did randomly sample
500 points in the domain every training
step um and in the in the boundary as
well um it's quite a large Network so it
has 10 layers and thousand thousand
hidden units so this is a fairly big
Network to be able to model this this
sort of function with this
complexity um it's using a soft plus
soft activation which is a continuous
version of a
redo um and an Adam
Optimizer now the big the big limitation
here and this is often the biggest
criticism of pins is the is the time it
takes just to run or to train this
network and this took one hour to to
train on a on a GPU um to get this
solution now if I compare that with
finite difference element finite
difference modeling how how long do you
think the finite difference solver took
just have a
guess yeah it took like 30 30 seconds to
a minute so this is this is completely
not uh competitive with finite
difference modeling in the Raw version
in the Raw format of a
pin so I'm going to be explaining um how
we get over that problem in in the next
lecture and how we speed up pins to make
them more
competitive I'm also going to try and ch
classify why pins are still useful for
inverse problems and uh and equation
disc Discovery in the next
slides okay so let's move on to using a
pin for an inverse problem so again let
me just explicitly say what the inverse
problem is and I'm going to be talking
about this same example using modeling
seismic wave through the earth I have
the wave equation and I have some now I
have some observations of the wavefield
here
and what I want to invert for is this
underlying velocity of the of the media
or maybe even where the source location
is as
well so how would we do this
traditionally traditionally we would
frame one way to solve an inverse
problem is to frame it as an
optimization problem and we just uh say
that we have our observations be and we
have some forward model with the system
given some guess of what the underlying
inputs are so this is a guess of the
Velocity model and we just minimize the
difference between our uh predicted
outputs and the true observed outputs
and um you know if f is differentiable
here if this is a finite difference Sol
which is differentiable we can just use
gradient descent on this subjective
function so how are pins different how
can pin solve this inverse problem in a
different
way okay so I'm going to explain how we
do it and what we do is very simple we
just change the loss function that we
use to train the pin so um it's a very
simple change that allows us to to solve
these invers
problems so again here's the loss
function for solving forward simulation
we've already looked at this
before where here this is the general
form of the L function but here the
differential operator might be the wave
equation for
example okay so if we're going to solve
the inverse problem what we do is we say
in general we have access to these extra
observations of the solution and so what
we're going to do is we're going to add
an extra term here where we say where we
have an observation of the the solution
we're going to match the noral network
output to that that observation so it's
an extra supervis loss that we can add
to the to the loss
function so that's the first change that
we do the second change we do is we say
okay in general we probably don't know
what the boundary conditions are of this
of the problem like let's just assume
that we don't have access to that we
just have observations solution so we we
get rid of the boundary
loss and then we keep the physics off
the same so we we we sample lots of
points in the in the domain just like we
did before and we and we evaluate the PD
residual now the the one other key
change we do is we
say okay well so this differentiable
operator it has some underlying
parameters that we want to try and
invert for these are the these are for
example in the wave equation it's this
velocity model here this C of as a
function of
X so to be able to solve this invest
problem and estimate what these are we
very the very simple trick is just to
say
okay these are just going to be extra
free parameters that we're going to
train inside of our Global training
algorithm when we're training the pin
like you know jointly when we're
learning the so we're going to learn
these underlying parameters five for
example um jointly when we're when we're
learning the values of
theta so you can imagine as the pin
trains it's not only like simultaneously
learning to solve the model forwards
it's also learning the underlying
parameters at the same time it's doing
some kind of joint optimization of of uh
of the
problem so this is kind of cool this is
very different to how I framed I framed
the inverse problem before where here
we're just solely focusing on optimizing
the underlying parameters and we're not
learning the solution we're just
differentiating through a
Sol so yeah it's a very interesting way
to to think about uh solving invest
problems and
and um this can be computationally
competitive with with a traditional
algorithm using gradient descent um
because we don't have to evaluate this
exp expensive forward solver anymore
we're just training a training a network
to fit the data so we don't have an
expensive forward solve in the inverse
outg so here's an example using again
pins for the wave equation but this time
we want to understand what the velocity
model is so that's just assume that we
have uh so this example is a VI
vibrating plate and uh what we do is we
just vibrate the plate and we measure
the displacement of the plate as a
function of time and this is used in
non-destructive testing for example to
investigate whether there's cracks in
the plate or any sort of perturbations
in in the
plate so you can see as this wave is
like propagating through the plate it
create there's some anomaly here which
is causing Reflections and so this we
want to investigate this a bit further
and so so given these observations so
this is real data by the way this paper
is actually taking real data of this of
this vibrating
plate so given these observations these
measurements of the displacement here
across the domain we're going to train
the network to match those and then
we're going to also add this loss this
physics loss in here which has the
velocity model here and we're going to
assume that we don't understand what the
velocity model is of this
plate and instead what we're going to do
is we're going to say okay instead of
knowing what the velocity is we're
actually going to approximate it with
another noral Network which has extra
three three parameters five so we can do
that we can just say velocity is a
function of X is just approximated by
some additional noral network with some
fre
parameters and when we train the noral
network we're going to jointly optimize
beta and fi at the same
time does that make sense to
everyone
yeah
okay so this is the result so what's
happening is when the pin trains it's it
slowly starts to fit the solution and
this is the output of the solution
Network here and at the same time it's
training that velocity model Network to
learn the velocity and we can query that
velocity Network at any point in space
just like we can query the solution
Network and this is what it predicts as
the underlying velocity and you can see
it's learned uh to find uh find this
crack in the in the in the plate and it
shows up as a perturbation in in the
velocity
model so I'm going to show you how to
I'm going to go back to my live coding
and I'm going to show you how to do this
with the damp harmonic oscillator and
we're going to learn what the code
efficient of friction is of the of the
oscillator and again I'm just going to
show you how easy this is to do in V
torch um so let me let me switch my
screen and go back to my My
Demo um so this is our second task we're
we're going to use the PIN to invert for
the underline
parameters so we again we have this loss
function where we don't have the
boundary loss anymore we still have the
physics loss and now we have this extra
loss where we have where we're matching
the Network's output to some observed
values
so I need to First just create some
noisy observational data that we can use
in this in this data
loss so this is just the code for doing
it and what I'm doing is sampling a
bunch of random points um in the domain
and I'm using the analytical solution to
get the values but I'm also adding a bit
of Gan noise to those observations so
I'm assuming that they're
noisy so now this is the same training
Loop that we had before um and I just
now need to adapt this training Loop so
that I can I treat the coefficient of FR
uh the Coe um yeah the coefficient of
friction mu here is a learnable
parameter so I need to jointly optimize
over mu and the weights of the N
Network so I'm G to we we have to start
with an initial guess of what mu is
that's how we can of start the gradient
to Center algorithm so I'm just going to
start with an in initial guess that mu
is just
one coefficient friction of one
now I'm in my in my loss function I'm
going to need the gradients of the loss
function with respect to me to be able
to update it so I again I need to make
sure that this is a tensor that requires
gradients so that I can Auto differ
it the other thing I'm going to do just
to help to pych is just to Define this
as a parameter this is just a wrapper
that just allows the optimizer to work
well uh doesn't do anything uh uh other
than that
and then I need to add me to my
Optimizer my T my P torch Optimizer so
that it knows to optimize this in its
gradient descent Loop so I'm just going
to I'm going to create the optimizer by
just copying um the optimizer
above and I'll just paste it in
here but originally we were just
optimizing the pins parameters so now we
need to add the new value as an extra
parameter to the optimizer so we just do
that by just converting this into a list
and then adding or appending me to that
list so this is telling the optimizer
when you're doing you know gradient
descent optimize me as well as the pins
parameters I've already copied and
pasted the physics loss uh into this
block and so the last thing I need to do
is Define the data loss so this should
be very simple so I'm just going to
compute the pins um
solution at the observe uh d The
observed time coordinates so these this
is this TS uh TS tensor here
uh where are we yep and then we're going
to just say that our second term in the
loss function is uh the mean squ
error of U minus the observed so these
are the noisy um noisy observations of
the solution and we're going to square
it uh so I think I think this all looks
good so now we can just retrain uh the
pin and so what I'm plotting here is the
noisy observation and the pin solution
as a function of training step and I'm
also plotting the value of mu as the
network trains so remember we're jointly
optimizing the solution and the underly
parameter at the same
time and uh depending on how many
observation points we have so basically
how well posed this inverse problem is
you know is is there enough information
in our observation and data points to be
able to solve the equation and also
estimate
M um depending on how many points there
are it depend depends on how well this
this converges but in this case it
converges well so we get a nice fit of
the solution and you can see that we
started with a guess of mu equals one
here and the optimizer initially
overshot and thought it was much higher
and then converged nicely on onto the
solution
okay um any questions on on this before
I move back to the
slides okay
[Music]
okay so here's one other example of
using pins for Inver problems before I
move on to the final application of pins
um and this is to carry out cardiac
activation mapping so this is a
completely different use case of pins
and here the the goal is to be able to
characterize the heart better and in
particular when when your heart beats um
the activation of the Heart Like travels
as as as like a wave across the heart
and you can actually map uh the time at
which the activations across the heart
occur and uh the underlying equation
here is the iol equation and it and it
tells us the relationship between the
velocity across the surface of the heart
and uh the time it takes for that for
that uh point on the surface to activate
when when the heartbeat
occurs so in general it's a really
useful medical diagnosis to be able to
understand this velocity model the
velocity of the heart to look for any
issues with your with your
heart um and so uh so the goal is
basically given observations of the
activation times across across the heart
can I understand what the underlying
velocity of the of the the the surface
of the heart
is so we can just make this for now just
a simple a simple 2D version of the
problem where we just have uh you know
um a an exact velocity model that looks
like this this is just a a simple toy
model for
now and uh we can actually plot the the
uh activation time that it takes uh if
uh across the heart here so this is the
activation time given this velocity
model um and uh so what we're going to
do is just use a a physics and form
Network to to fit both uh the velocity
and the activation times at the same
time and we're just going to use a
physics loss here where the noral
network approximates the activation time
and also approximates the the velocity
here with these three these theter and
fire
weights and we just match the noral
network this approximately activation
time with the observed time points that
we have so these these time points in
the domain
here um and so what you see
this is the exact solution and um this
is the result of the pin so the pin is
able to accurately approximate these
activation times and also get a fairly
good inversion of what the underlying
velocity structure is so this this
comparison here is is is if we just use
train that naive Neal network with just
the just the um the observational times
and not the the ionol equation
residual um and you can see it it does a
much worse kind of interpolation of
velocity without that understanding of
the physics equation in the loss
function you can also compare it to just
using a gan process to do to interpolate
these State points and also a linear
aggression and and it's clear that the
pin with this extra regularization and
its loss function is is is the better
better model
here okay so in the last uh five or 10
minutes I'm G to move on and say how we
can actually use pins to start
discovering the underlying differential
itself rather than just these parameters
of the of the
equation uh so so here's the setup we
used for for solving invers problems
with pins we said we jointly optimize
the weights of the network to simulate
the problem but also the underlying
parameters of the differential equation
F so the question now is well how do we
actually learn D this differentiable
operator rather than just some
parameters of the
operator um so what we're going to do is
we're going to say okay we're going to
assume that D is composed of many
different differentiable
operators um and we're going to build a
library of this operator so we're going
to say rpde could contain any
combination of these of these operators
so for example the partial derivative of
the solution with respect to x with
respect to T the second order
derivatives in their
combinations and then we make the
assumption that the differential
operator can just be represented is this
Lambda Matrix here so this is a matrix
of coefficients multiplied by this uh
this uh libr Library Vector of of of
different
operators so for example if if we were
going to represent the damp harmonic
oscillator in this in this way we would
have this library of of uh of operators
and this coefficient Matrix which in
this case it's just a it's just a Col
it's just a row
Vector so you can see here where we
don't need the operator we'll just set a
coefficient in that Matrix to be zero so
we only need the first three
coefficients in in this
library and then the goal of learning
the equation then turns to a a goal
turns into a problem of learning these
coefficients of this uh of this Lambda
Matrix so this is how we would frame the
Lost function and and train the PIN to
do equation Discovery and and uh yeah we
would have have instead of the
differential operator we would now have
we would replace it with this this
Lambda Matrix Times by our library of of
possible
operators so
um uh this in general is a harder
problem than just solving inverse
problems inverse problems are already
hard to solve when you have one second
yeah they they're already hard to solve
when you have a lot of when you don't
have enough observational data so this
is an even harder problem to to do a
regression over all of these uh
these operators
yeah yeah so we we are assuming it
linear combination if we use this this
uh uh Matrix times uh operators Vector
but you don't have to assume that so if
you knew that there was nonlinear terms
well you could you could include non
nonlinear terms inside this Library so
you could have U Times by DX or DX Times
by DT for
example um
so depending on the kind of space of
possible op differentiable or yeah
differential equations that you want to
be able to model you choose that
Library
yeah yeah yeah that's that's typically
the way it's done but there are other
ways to approach it as
well but so what I'm getting at is that
this space of possible differential
equations brow like exponentially it's a
huge space of C if you imagine all the
combinations of all these operators
that's that's absolutely massive comb
combinatorial space to search so this is
actually a really hard problem in
general and and what we typically have
to do is to assert some regularization
or prior on the coefficients of the
differential equation so we we so for
example we assume something like sparity
we say we want to we want to find a
differential equation that has the
minimum number of of operators possible
by for example adding a an extra
regularization determine the loss
function that says you know their Landa
Valu should be sparse they should tend
towards zero and this helps make that
that uh the problem converge and be more
of a well posed
problem and other than that we just fit
in the same way we do with an inverse
problem we have observations of the
solution and we just fit the network to
those observations and and this is once
we fit those observations then we're
regressing the gradients to get what the
underlying equation
is any other questions
okay so this is a paper that did exactly
the process that I just described came
out in nature Communications a couple
years
ago um and yeah they're doing exactly
this so they have a data loss where
they're matching the the Network
Solutions to some observational data uh
then they have the physics loss which is
minimizing the PD residual but using
this uh library of operators and and
trying to learn the the coefficients of
those operators
and then it adds some sparse sparity
regularization to try and minimize the
number of coefficients that we that we
use and it's trained by doing like a
alternating training where they first
learn the weights of the network so they
first fit to the solution data and then
they do a step where they learn the
coefficients and this turns this seems
to be better than just doing a joint
optimization so yeah you this is an
example from the paper uh this is an
example of pin is discovering Burger
equation in the in the kind of sense of
doing a linear linear aggression on the
coefficients um so their input data here
were just noisy measurements of of
solutions of the burgers equation for
different initial conditions as you can
see here and just given those
observations and their assumed library
of of operators they were able to
discover coefficients that you know gave
a very close approximation to the true
true PD at the botom
okay so uh We've covered quite a lot
I've explained to you what pins are and
how to train them and I've also showed
you that we can use them across forward
inverse sign equation Discovery problems
um really important thing is that
they're mesh free so they give you a
functional approximation to the solution
rather than just a discretized
version and so they that's a direct
approximation to the solution so next
lecture I'll talk about the limitations
of pins um and all all the many possible
extensions that people use the the pins
pins are extended by so yep I'll see you
see you next lecture thank you